hi guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to sean
connery's interview with barbara walters
so this was a comment left in my comment
section and it just sounded interesting
i don't even watch this guy yes oh yeah
i like that
the friendship mean a lot friendship
with men oh yeah i like that
i think that's one of the um
the pleasures of golf as well i'm not
mad i don't like playing golf with women
no matter how good they are i really
don't your wife plays golf she's a very
good golfer yeah
why not because i don't like playing
golf with women why not i like the
company of men better than golf
why it's very difficult to explain it's
just
um the it's more
pleasurable playing golf with with men
than women
yes i can tell she's really mad
but it's weird i'm not even offended
like i feel like that's the equivalent
of like
having a night out with the girls to go
you did an interview
which may come back to haunt you what
you know what i'm going to say right no
okay you did an interview in which you
said it's not the worst thing to slap a
woman now and then as i remember you
said you don't do it with a clenched
fist it's better to do it with an open
hand yeah remember that
yeah yeah i didn't love that i haven't
changed my opinion
you have it no not at all you think it's
good to slap a woman
no i don't think it's good i think it
must i don't think it's
that bad i think that it depends
entirely on the circumstances and if it
merits it
yeah what would merit it well if you
have
tried everything else and women are
pretty good at this
they can't leave it alone yeah they
don't want to have the
the last word and you give them the
laugh last word but they're not happy
with the last one
they want to say it again and and
get into a really provocative situation
then
i think it's absolutely right to give a
good slap
yeah absolutely what if she gives you a
good slap back
well then you get into another area i
mean then
maybe she's getting to like it then it
becomes something else i don't know
but uh no no i seriously i think that
the
it's the last resort he's not going to
do it because he wants to do it
huh wait will people see this interview
are you going gonna get mail
no i i disagree with that that is insane
there is no good reason to slap a grown
ass woman
unless like she's attacking you first
like you know what i mean if a woman's
like assaulting you
there comes a point where like
you run out of options i would imagine
but like there are very few
circumstances where you should be able
to slap a woman
might get some female
well do you ever slap your wife no no
she doesn't provoke it
no yeah yeah well she takes me to the
wire she's very you know
she's she's very much got her own views
and opinion and everything and she's
french
and you know they are quite pragmatic
and
but no i mean
she's tiny anyway you know and uh but i
have
i have a very violent temper i have and
i don't i wouldn't want to stop
uh heading
but i'm also quite strong
what makes your marriage work
that my wife has
a lot of interests and things she's and
totally absorbed
with me and
we have enough separations that's we've
been doing
some things all the time so we come back
here there's always something to talk
about
i i couldn't be with the same person
all day that's important if you're
around the same person like 24 7
sometimes you just like cause problems
it would bore me to tears do you believe
in fidelity
do i believe in fidelity yeah
yeah i believe in fidelity yeah your
wife is totally absorbed in you
yeah are you totally absorbed in your
wife as much as i can be yeah
but as i say i have to go for example if
i go to make a film
she doesn't come with me the first week
i just
i can come and go and do exactly what i
need to do to get it right for me
and she understands that and
so she has sufficient interest in things
herself anyway not to need to be
sitting there i swore
when i was preparing the questions for
this interview that i would not use
the phrase male chauvinist but you
are a male chauvinist right and what is
a male chauvinist he's offended
it's a guy who kind of it's that's all
sort of macho
uh you know women are kind of nice as
long as they're not
too much around and a good whack
i don't know kind of fatty never happens
well you said you don't mind
giving them a little wax you're lifting
it right out of the car
then you tell me something you tell me i
don't profess to be macho i don't
profess to walk around smacking her i
never smacked my wife
uh it's the attitude
i think he's actually saying that
like it's a last resort i don't agree
but i don't think he's saying like you
should
hit your significant other all the time
but that's still interesting you mean
i should my attitude should be different
but i'm talking about this okay
well i don't like playing golf with
women that's a crime
i actually am not offended by the golf
comment at all
it's it's the equivalent of going like
out with the girls
i don't go and insist playing with them
so why should they
come and just playing with me also in
the golf club when there's a room for
men only i think it's terrific and why
would they want to go in if they're not
wanted there
huh now i swear i could go and say well
where's the ladies club here i must go
and
get some games with these wonderful 36
handicappers and
you know what i mean
how do you feel about the equal rights
amendment do you know that the amendment
we're trying to have passed in our
country
well i think i think it's unequal rights
now with the women i think they've got
everything going
you do it gets into uh
i think that you should get paid if you
do the equal job yeah
i know i work harder and earn more money
to make things happen which has been my
role since i can remember
and uh if the guy is going to be the one
that's got to go out and do the work
to feed everybody so that they can have
the kids or go to school have a car or
whatever
then he has they have to give him a
primary consideration
no now there's there are some exchanges
where the wife says okay i'm going to
work and you can do the cooking and
bring up the kids
well if some men are suited for that i
think it's terrific
i don't think i'd be very good at that i
don't think you'd be very good at that
either
when it's better i should do something
i'm good at
then she would be happy too no what
about both working
and both helping at the house and both
helping with the kids
well that happens in part
but i just feel like it doesn't matter
like
do what you want with your life no one's
stopping you
do you respect a woman's opinion as much
as a man's
but of course okay of course why
wouldn't i
all right but you know there are stupid
women huh
and they're stupid yeah yes and that's
why when people say
like respect women i'm like it depends
on the woman i don't respect all women
some women are idiots
some are very smart some are smarter
than me okay
so you you we haven't cornered the
market on all our faults eh
we've been talking somewhat seriously
but somewhat teasingly too do you mind
when someone says you're a male
chauvinist you've heard it before
i don't mind honestly no sean what do
you think is the biggest fault
in your opinion that a person can have a
biggest fault
yeah you mean other than being sure this
is gonna make a shove in this pic
um
stupid i hate stupidity
more than anything same actually finish
this for me
sean connery is
almost a male chauvinist pig
you can tell
you could tell barbara walters like
kind of likes it not like like is
flirting with him or anything but she
like
kind of thinks he's funny and likes him
but she also
is kind of disgusted by the stuff he
says
but it is what it is i didn't think that
interview
was as bad as a lot of people made it
out to be like
the only part that boiled my blood a
little bit
was the slapping that's
you should not hit a woman that is not
okay but like what are you saying with
the golf stuff like
i hate golf i do not care if they have
a golf club that i can't go into but let
me know in the comments if you agree
with me if you disagree with me
either way let me know i always value
you guys's opinion so let me know in the
comments don't forget to like
comment and subscribe